now votes are being counted in kenya
after a lower than expected turnout in
tuesday's general election voters are
selecting a new president and choosing
members of the country's parliament
early indicators are showing a tight
race between the two main candidates
deputy president william ruto and
veteran opposition leader raila odinga
are both projected to having close to 50
of the vote and that means a runoff
election may be needed
and for more on this we can cross
straight to nairobi now and speak to our
correspondent there edith kimani hi
edith the the turnout in this election
was really quite low especially among
younger voters tell us why that was
well if i was to summarize it into one
word it would be money a lot of people
here in kenya are simply grappling with
just how to survive on a regular basis
there was a viral video that went out
about a month ago of a lady who went to
the supermarket and upon realizing that
the price of maizeflower which is a
staple here in kenya was two dollars up
from one dollar and 20 cents she just
started screaming and almost sort of
lost her mind one might describe and
this is sort of what is on the mind of
most canyons every day i have people
asking me for money ask me for jobs and
this is not unique to me personally this
is just a state of affairs in the
country and this is what is on the minds
of people and so an election doesn't
seem so important
so a lot of pressure on the person who
will be president next can you tell us
about the two men who are running for
president and what policies we could
expect from each of them
railaudinger being uh the veteran in uh
this race he is 77 years old certainly
not a new face in kenyan politics he has
held various positions for member of
parliament right up to uh prime minister
he is actually saying that he's tried
and tested hands that's his promise that
he's going to sort out issues of health
care that he's going to finally end
corruption which is endemic in this
country and the thing that is most
important to most uh to kenya's
listening to him is that he's going to
provide a 50 stipend for those who do
not have a salary or who don't have jobs
uh william ruto his contender is
newer in the political scene by no means
a rookie he is himself also very much in
the kenyan political game has been for a
while he's held various positions right
up to the deputy president and his uh
promise is that he is going to put the
grassroots people first the the local
man he's saying that he's going to have
a bottom-up approach that's what he's
calling it and so both of these
contenders are saying that they're going
to put the kenyan first and what is
ironic is that most kenyans feel that
they're not being placed anywhere in
this election
so whoever does win what needs to be
their number one priority
absolutely looking at what's happening
with the state of the economy as i
mentioned earlier the quality of life
here for most kenyans is exceptionally
poor of course that has been made worse
by the war in ukraine uh we're still
reeling from the effects of the global
pandemic that we are still actually
experiencing and there's a drought that
is currently ongoing so that will have
to be top of the agenda uh for the
person who does come in to take over the
khamani
government
nairobi thank you so much